Ayahuasca is a drug and hallucinogenic drug used by South American tribes
For centuries during spiritual ceremonies. But they are becoming more prevalent among those who are looking
About audio and visual hallucinations, but what exactly is ayahuasca? And how it affects your body
And your brain?
In fact, ayahuasca is a combination of the leaves of the psychotria viridis,
And another plant vine called Banisteriopsis caapi - while neither of them causes hallucinations alone.
But the leaves contain DMT (dimethyltriptamine), which is similar to the composition of the structure
The neurotransmitter serotonin in your body and the chemicals in the mushroom-mushrooms!
The problem is that your stomach enzymes naturally disrupt the DMT before it is absorbed
In the course of your blood; and here comes the role of Karma. It inhibits your stomach enzymes
Work well, and allow the DMT to move through your bloodstream to your brain
To cross the blood-brain barrier.
The effects of this drink usually appear, about half an hour after they are taken, and their hallucinogenic effect peaks
An hour later, it begins to disappear within six hours. But
It is reported that these hallucinogens are different from real estate such as LSD and mushroom - the mushrooms - most people are aware of
Absolutely their visual hallucination. In addition, instead of 'hearing voices'
The audible sounds are usually merely exacerbated by the noise around them.
Unlike those who use LSD and Mushroom Mushroom for fun, many people drink ayahuasca
Seeking reconciliation with their thoughts and feelings and painful events in the past and present.
After that, most feel comfortable and more receptive to their thoughts
And their current status.
The default mode network is a characteristic area of ​​the brain, if it is hyperactive, it accompanies it
Feeling stressed, depressed and social phobia. A magnetic resonance scan of the brain shows that ayahuasca is causing
Significant decrease in activity within the network default mode. Where this activity is associated
Usually with the meditative state this explains the reason for the feeling of those who seek out audio and visual hallucinations,
And some of the Ayahuasca poets to peace with themselves, and to create their renewed sense of purpose
After returning from the trip effect of the property.
In addition, DMT has been associated with proteins that promote long-term memory retention,
Neural plasticity, the re-formation of new neurons. The DMT can bind to specific receptors
Such as those found on the mitochondria and the endoplasmic network, and may have the ability to kill
Specific cancer cells. In addition, alkaloids taken from karma have been shown to lead to the death of cancer cells
In mouse skin and specific cells in the human liver. But this does not mean that ayahuasca is considered
An alternative to radiotherapy and chemotherapy, but may enter the future within
Cancer Research. Interestingly, unlike other real estate such as alcohol and cocaine, it does not cause ayahuasca
Immunity to the body, so regular users do not need to increase the amount
To achieve the same effect they tried the first time.
After treatment, I always suffer from severe vomiting and diarrhea;
Because the drink is very acidic, it becomes the stomach of its users usually disturbed, even for those who drink it heavily
A dark side of Ayahuasca, too, has been linked as a cause of death, especially among tourists,
Although the method of death is often not determined. This rise in popularity of the drink
To the high number of false shamans and priests, who are not qualified to manufacture it safely.
Ultimately, the data is now too small to take a serious look at Oceanic as a way of entertainment.
We need more clinical trials to assess whether ayahuasca is safe.
Special thanks to Audible for their support to this episode and to give you 30 days free experience on
audible.com/asap. This week, we wanted to recommend Oliver Sachs' "Hallucinations."
To take you deeply to the many circumstances that stimulate hallucinations,
And explain how common in reality! You can get 30 free days at audible.com/asap
The selection of the huge group! We love them as they are a good choice when you are on your way by car.
Follow us to get more scientific videos weekly! Translation: team translate - Twitter: @autrjim